m
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes au centre
culturel jean vilar à marly le roi voici
le sommaire
du théâtre de la danse ou encore du
champ le centre culturel jean vilar de
marly le roi propose de nombreux
spectacles durant sa saison 2021 2022
nous parlerons de la programmation avec
la directrice du centre culturel à
versailles au carré à la farine le salon
de la société versaillaise des articles
ile de france revient pour une 150e
édition plus de 60 artistes exposent
leurs oeuvres et puis enfin une
compétition de courts métrages sera
organisé à l'île maurice béjart verneuil
sur seine à l'occasion du festival les
images vagabond
[Musique]
je me trouve dans la salle de spectacle
du centre culturel jean vilar de
marly-le-roi cette salle de 2 149 places
accueille de nombreux spectacles
différents alors cette saison 2021 2022
a bien débuté sophie lorain bonjour
bonjour vous êtes la directrice du
centre culturel alors combien de
spectacles sont proposés cette année
alors cette année est une saison qui est
un peu particulière les en raison des
reports dus à la crise sanitaire plus
importante que d'habitude donc nous
avons à peu près 35 spectacles en séance
tout public et en séance scolaire alors
quelle est la programmation cette année
alors c'est une programmation qui est
pluridisciplinaire on fait du théâtre
classique ou contemporain un peu de
danse de la musique classique ou de la
chanson de la musique du monde du ciné
concerts des spectacles pour le jeune
public des spectacles pour tout public
alors j'ai vu que vous faisiez donc les
y avait des compagnies qui venais ici en
résidence mais ce que c'est important de
soutenir ces artistes qui créent c'est
fondamental même c'est essentiel si on
veut des spectacles il faut bien donner
les moyens aux compagnies de les créer
et les moyens sont de tous ordres donnés
un plateau à des compagnies pour répéter
c'est important donner du temps du temps
pour créer quand on crée il faut avoir
le temps de se tromper le temps de
chercher de recommencer de partir dans
une autre direction et si le coït a eu
un intérêt c'était peut-être celui ci
c'était de nous donner un peu plus de
temps pour la création de spectacles
donc sur l'année la saison précédente
pardon nous avons accueilli dix
compagnies en résidence au théâtre le
théâtre était fermée au public mais nous
avons eu la chance voilà de pouvoir
accueillir ces compagnies de les
accompagner dans leurs projets j'ai vu
aussi que le centre jean vilar centre
culturel jean vilar
soutient les pratiques artistiques
amateurs est-ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer ce que c'est en quoi
consiste oui alors c'est un petit peu
l'adn du centre culturel le centre
culturel est une association formée
d'associations
les associations qui le composent sont
des associations de pratiques
artistiques amateurs en théâtre et en
danse en musique et en chansons en
poésie en improvisation et donc elle
bénéficie du plateau du théâtre pour
présenter leurs heures dans l'année
voilà et puis nous les soutenons
également
en techniquement par la lumière le son
etc nous pouvons les aider aussi parfois
juridiquement quand il peut y avoir un
souci nous essayons d accompagner au
mieux et donc il ya une programmation
amateurs qui est parallèle à la
programmation professionnelle très bien
justement vous parlez de programmation
cette programmation riche en au centre
culturel de janvier jean vilar et bien
nous nous avons assisté à l'un des
spectacles les caprices de marianne
regarder
celio est amoureux de marianne mais
malheureusement marianne est déjà marié
c'est une histoire d'amour qui se joue à
la salle de spectacles jean vilar à
marly-le-roi et caprices de marianne
pièce écrite par alfred de musset et
mise en scène par rock antoine
albaladejo
on passe d'un lieu à un autre
en une seconde
d'une ruelle à l'intérieur d'une chambre
un petit salon et donc du coup cette
particularité donne un côté très
dynamique et presque cinématographique à
la pièce et moi c'est ça aussi qui m'a
beaucoup plu parce que du coup on avait
imaginé tout un travail sur les liaisons
sont passés d'une scène à l'autre et
pour cela un orchestre et mis en place
puisque la pièce revisitant version
cabaret chicago
[Musique]
et puis l'originalité c'est la mise en
musique ou en fait on a vraiment un
répertoire on a créé un répertoire d'une
dizaine de chansons que nous avons écrit
nous mêmes
musicalement on s'est inspiré aussi
d'autres chansons des standards de jazz
ou autres personnages emblématiques de
la pièce octave amis de ces lieux il va
tout faire pour intercéder en sa faveur
auprès de marianne c'est un peu un des
musiciens du groupe qui a été constituée
et qu'un petit peu l'animation et le
choeur bâton de débats font de ce
spectacle personnage d'octave est un
personnage qui a une trajectoire
absolument incroyable dramaturgiquement
c'est un personnage qui est là
l'allégorie presque de l'insouciance est
livré sur scène ils sont neuf comédiens
mais ils ont aussi la particularité
d'être musicien une interprétation
pluriel pour parfaire cette histoire
d'amour alors sophie laure at on vient
de voir cette pièce de théâtre j'imagine
que d'autres pièces sont programmés
reste qu'elle vous pouvez peut-être me
donner trois temps forts de cette saison
et 2021 2022 avec plaisir alors très
prochainement le vendredi 19 novembre
nous accueillons sur un air de tango qui
est une pièce contemporaine écrite par
isabelle de toledo et mise en scène par
bénédicte belibi et pascal faber c'est
une histoire d'amour entre un père et
son fils deux hommes qui ont
mis du temps avant d'arriver à se parler
à se dire les choses le fils tient un
bar en bord de mer il se noie dans son
travail il en néglige probablement sa
femme et ses enfants et son père lui est
un homme tout de légèreté qui aiment la
danse le tango les paillettes et ces
deux hommes et bien vous vous trouvez
comment se parler ils vont mettre du
temps et c'est c'est vraiment une pièce
qui donne envie à la fin de voilà de
décrocher son téléphone et d'appeler son
père pour lui dire papa je t'aime voilà
c'est c'est plein d'amour et de
tendresse s'y faire c'est très beau la
deuxième temps fort alors je vous
proposerai le 4 décembre c'est un samedi
à 20h30 nous accueillons réfugiés
poétique alors c'est un titre qui peut
faire un peu peur mais c'est un
spectacle de poésie de douceur de grâce
on est dans un un square avec un
vagabond ce vagabond est interprété par
une danseuse et un petit peu comme un
personnage de charlot il est il va
essayer de rompre sa solitude de
convoquer l'imaginaire les barrières
vont devenir des bateaux la neige tombée
on est transporté ailleurs c'est un
spectacle plein de douceur plein de
poésie et de troisième temps fort alors
comme nous faisons des spectacles de
genres très différents je vous
proposerai au mois de janvier il me faut
une antisèche le 29 janvier nous
accueillons l'oukase a dans son deuxième
spectacle qui est consacrée à brel et
barbara et donc le groupe lou casar et
interprète complètement les chansons de
ses deux artistes magnifique poète et
interprète qu'on était prêt les barbara
ce sont des textes magnifiques qui
parlent d'amour qui parlent d'amitié qui
parle de la vie c'est fait pour tout
public mais bien merci beaucoup sur les
jours à ce même arrêté le principe et
merci merci à vous
le festival de blues sur thème revient
pour une 22e édition l'an passé il n'y
avait pas eu d'événement due à la crise
sanitaire les membres du festival et les
artistes sont donc heureux de remonter
sur scène avec une programmation de 14
grands concerts et centaine d'artistes
bien sûr autour du blues on écoute
chantal ce type et betty la présidente
du festival nous commençons donc le
douce avec jean jacques béchio qui est
un harmoniciste on ne présente plus est
le plus grand en france nous aurons
également une soirée entièrement
figurines de bosses féminin ali mais le
13 novembre avec laura cox en propre et
ensuite j'ai syrie nous aurons également
une création que nous évidemment qui a
mis du temps à se mettre en place du
fait guère co-lead nous allons avoir
un groupe qui s'appelle opus james qui
est un groupe vocal a cappella ils sont
six
ils viendront le vendredi 26 novembre à
la collégiale
[Musique]
et on part à versailles à présent plus
de 60 artistes exposent au 156e salon de
la société versaillaise et ile de france
jusqu'au 21 novembre
peintre ou encore dessinateur
présenteront leurs travaux au carré à la
farine salle d'exposition à versailles
sculptures en terre cuite un papier ou
encore peinture à l'huile plus d'une
soixante dix oeuvres sont à découvrir au
156e salon de la société versailles et
des artistes d'ile-de-france au carré à
la farine à versailles les artistes qui
sont professionnels ont la possibilité
de mettre trois oeuvres et les non
professionnels parce qu'il y en a quand
même qui sont très intéressants ont la
possibilité de mettre une oeuvre nous
avons la dèche est sculpteur en tout une
soixantaine d'artistes présents ils
viennent uniquement de la région ile de
france comme cet artiste yvelinois ce
qui fait des sculptures en papier
patiner autour du roman d'alice au pays
des merveilles mais aussi autour des
animaux et de l'humain toutes ces pièces
ont une armature comme une colonne
vertébrale c'est un film qui court le
long du corps
ensuite je travaille avec des fils
d'aluminium que je tricote un petit peu
tout autour de la pièce certains sont
visibles à votre oeil d'autres me serve
d'armature autre invité d'honneur du
salon siméon colin il dessine et peint
des arbres ou des éléments comme des
branches ou des feuillages jeu j'adore
les cèdres les chaînes il ya des abus
que j'aime moins parce que le château
moins de caractère ce qui m'intéresse
dans les arbres c'est effectivement la
qualité des cavités entre les broches
quand les branches se découpent bien
qu'elle sait et aime une certaine
lourdeur une certaine amplitude une
certaine certaines protections en
quelque sorte 24 artistes yvelinois ont
participé à cet événement le salon de la
société versaillaise des artistes d'île
de france est présentée jusqu'au
dimanche 21 novembre
le festival les images vagabonde
organisé par l'association de cinéma
contrechamp met à l'honneur les courts
métrages vendredi 19 novembre neuf
courts-métrages seront proposées au
public à l'espace maurice béjart de
verneuil sur seine on en parle avec un
membre de l'association de contrôle
[Musique]
le fils ilan les images avaient fait la
gamme honda festival annuel que
l'association de contrechamp
l'association de programmation et
d'éducation à l'image dans 78 propose
donc
pour fêter le cinéma fait revivre les
cinémas sur le territoire nous sommes
tous et cette année c'est particulier
parce que c'est la dixième année et ce
qui est encore plus particulier c'est
que la précédente édition s'est faite en
ligne et là on va pouvoir enfin
rencontrer les spectateurs
ce court métrage viennent alors de taper
à peu près partout on a eu des courts
métrages qui donnait d'angleterre par
exemple mais aussi des courts métrages
un peu plus près de région parisienne
mais aussi des courts métrages qui
viennent par exemple d'un produit
national de toulouse d'un peu partout
fait on voyage à travers ses courts
métrages
traitent soirée c'est une soirée donc de
compétition de courts métrages donc il
va se dérouler à un accueil du public
qui va pouvoir découvrir mes recours
métrages et 20 qui va pouvoir voter pour
le premier court métrage a découvert
découvrir aussi des jeunes talents et
pas pour pour ce vote donc y aura le
vote du public naturellement mais aussi
un jury professionnel qui sera
constituée pour voter et il y aura une
remise de kits numéraire donc aux
camions et c'est la fin de ce set 8
culture merci de nous avoir suivis
rendez vous la semaine prochaine dans un
autre lieu culturel yves binois bonne
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]